There's the part of you that's healthy, and there's the part of you that's sick. And sometimes the healthy part doesn't want to admit there's a sick part. Well, back in 1945, Walt Strommer was wounded in the Battle of the Bulge. He was permanently blinded, sent home.
人的一部分是健康的，另一部分则是生病的。有时健康的那部分人不想承认还有生病的那部分。好吧，回到1945年，沃尔特·斯特罗默在突出部战役中受伤了。他永久失明，被送回了家。
For the next year or so, when I was back home going to college, I would dream that I was driving a car. And then in the dream I would think, "You shouldn't be doing this. You're blind."
之后一年左右，我回到家上大学时，经常会梦见自己在开车。在梦里我会想：“你不该做这种事。你是盲人。”
In fact, he realized, in his dream, he was always able to see. And even to this day, over 50 years later, he still has these dreams from time to time.
事实上，他意识到在梦中他总是能看见东西。直到今天，五十多年过去了，他有时还会做这样的梦。
Sometimes I will dream of myself as I was as a teenager. And those dreams are almost completely as I would have been then, seeing. Or occasionally, I will still, in dreams, see a page of a book and read it, and absolutely clearly, and I may even remember a sentence or two when I wake up.
有时我会梦见自己还是十几岁时的样子。那些梦几乎和我当时一模一样，能看见东西。或者偶尔，在梦中我仍然会看见书页并阅读它，非常清晰，醒来时甚至能记住一两句话。
Mr. Strommer says it took 10 or 15 years of blindness before he showed up in his own dreams as a blind person. And at some point, he started to wonder, "Why the delay?" He wrote a letter to a publication called Paraplegia News asking if anybody else had the same experience. He got a handful of letters from people who had.
斯特罗默先生说，他失明了10到15年后，才在自己的梦中以盲人的形象出现。在某个时刻，他开始纳闷：“为什么会有这种延迟？”他给一份名为《截瘫新闻》的刊物写了一封信，询问是否还有其他人有同样的经历。他收到了几封有类似经历的人的回信。
Some of them started seeing themselves as in wheelchairs or paralyzed-- whatever-- within a few months. Others it was years before it was incorporated. And I think almost all of them say it's inconsistent. Sometimes they will see themselves as in a wheelchair, the next time not. I think one of the more amusing ones was the man who said he would go along in his wheelchair and he gets to a curb that the chair won't get up on. So he gets out of the chair, lifts it up on the curb, and then he gets back in and goes on his way. Or one woman wrote about she will dream that she's walking with her husband, and he's pushing her wheelchair. And then he sees somebody coming. He says, "Quick, get back in your wheelchair. People are coming."
有些人几个月内就开始在梦中看到自己坐在轮椅上或瘫痪——不管怎样。另一些人则过了好几年才在梦中体现出来。我想他们几乎都说这并不连贯。有时他们会梦见自己坐在轮椅上，下次又不会。我觉得其中比较有趣的一封信，是一个人说他坐在轮椅上走，遇到一个轮椅上不去的路缘石。于是他从轮椅上下来，把轮椅抬上路缘石，然后又坐回去继续赶路。还有一位女士写道，她梦见和丈夫一起散步，丈夫推着她的轮椅。然后他看见有人走过来，就说：“快，回到轮椅上。有人来了。”
Here's a letter that you were sent. An older man writes, "I've been in a wheelchair since October 6, 1966. And during the dream state, I've never visualized myself in a wheelchair. I've been impotent since 1962, but in dreams, I see myself as a stud that can go out with any of the cute, young things."
这里有一封寄给你的信。一位老人写道：“从1966年10月6日起，我就一直坐轮椅。在梦境中，我从未梦见自己坐在轮椅上。我从1962年起就阳痿了，但在梦里，我把自己看作是一个可以和任何可爱的年轻女孩约会的种马。”
Yes. That comes through in a couple of the letters. And as I recall, one of the people wrote-- I guess I had raised the question, why doesn't the dreaming brain catch up and show you the reality? And she said, "Why should it? Why should it be in a hurry to show us the unpleasant side of life? Maybe part of the function of dreams is to give us a few minutes of respite and happiness so we can come out of it and say, 'Hey, that felt pretty good.'"
是的。这在几封信中都体现出来了。我记得其中一个人写道——我想我当时提出了这个问题，为什么做梦的大脑不能跟上进度，让你看到现实？她说：“为什么要跟上？为什么急着向我们展示生活中不愉快的一面？也许梦的功能之一就是给我们几分钟的喘息和快乐，这样我们醒来后可以说，‘嘿，那种感觉真好。’”
One man, a wheelchair user, wrote, "This is better than just a harmless fantasy. It means I can re-experience walking and running temporarily. I wake up mentally refreshed, at ease." Mr. Strommer was a college professor, and he spent some time researching why our subconscious minds would take so long to absorb the new facts about our lives, why his brain took a decade to admit to itself in dreams that he was blind. He says nobody really knows why. It might be chemical, or it might simply be that it's common for us all to see ourselves one way when in reality we're not that way at all.
一位坐轮椅的人写道：“这不仅仅是一种无害的幻想，它更好。这意味着我可以暂时重新体验走路和奔跑。醒来时我精神焕发，感到轻松。”斯特罗默先生曾是一名大学教授，他花了一些时间研究为什么我们的潜意识需要这么长时间才能吸收关于我们生活的新事实，为什么他的大脑花了一十年才在梦中承认自己失明了。他说没人真正知道原因。这可能是化学作用，也可能仅仅是因为我们都很常见地以某种方式看待自己，而实际上我们根本不是那样。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it is This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, Defying Sickness. Act One, Road Trip. A father and a son go on a long car ride to figure out what parts of the father's brain have not been lost yet to Alzheimer's disease and to try to jump-start his memories. Act Two, My World Record, a hemophiliac's adventures at motocross racing and at setting another world's record. Act Three-- well, just stay tuned for Act Three. We'll launch Act One after some music.
这里是WBEZ芝加哥和公共广播国际台的《美国生活》节目。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的节目主题是“抗击疾病”。第一幕，公路旅行。一对父子踏上长途车之旅，试图找出父亲大脑中哪些部分还没有被阿尔茨海默病侵蚀，并试图重启他的记忆。第二幕，“我的世界纪录”，一个血友病患者在摩托车越野赛中冒险并创造了另一项世界纪录。第三幕——嗯，敬请期待第三幕。我们将在播放音乐后开启第一幕。
Act One, Road Trip. Joel Meyerowitz is a photographer, grew up in New York City. But for the last two decades, his parents have lived in Florida. Joel would see them, visit for a few days at a time. But over the past 10 years, Joel's father, Hy, developed Alzheimer's. Before he retired, Hy was a salesman for 40 years and did a few years as a comic in a vaudeville act before that. He was a boxer, won his weight class in the very first Golden Gloves competition. But now that he had Alzheimer's, the doctor said that he should stay inside, avoid a lot of stimulation. His son Joel thought, "What if we try, just for a brief time, something different?"
第一幕，公路旅行。乔尔·迈耶罗维茨是一位摄影师，在纽约市长大。但在过去的二十年里，他的父母一直住在佛罗里达。乔尔会去探望他们，每次待几天。但在过去的10年里，乔尔的父亲海伊患上了阿尔茨海默病。在退休前，海伊做了40年的推销员，在此之前还在杂耍表演中当过几年的喜剧演员。他曾是一名拳击手，在第一届金手套拳击比赛中赢得了他那个重量级的冠军。但现在他患了阿尔茨海默病，医生说他应该待在家里，避免过多的刺激。他的儿子乔尔心想：“如果我们尝试一下，哪怕是很短的时间，做些不一样的事情呢？”
I was visiting my father. We were driving someplace and he was babbling on, as he does. His great skill is that he can talk. And in the middle of one of these riffs, he turned to me with a look of panic, really, and he said, "The trouble with me is I never get to the point where I get to the point." And that was so pungent an observation about his predicament that it entered my consciousness in a way that made me say, now. That's it. I'm going to make a film about him. He's at a place in this disease where, before he's completely gone and while he has some consciousness about his situation, I'm going to take him out into the world again and see what happens to him and how he handles himself.
当时我正在探望我的父亲。我们正开车去某个地方，他像往常一样喋喋不休。他最大的本事就是能说。在这些胡言乱语中间，他带着惊慌的表情转向我，说：“我的问题在于我永远说不到重点。”这个对他的困境的观察是如此尖锐，以至于它进入了我的意识，让我说，就是现在。就是这个。我要为他拍一部电影。他正处于这种疾病的一个阶段，在他完全丧失意识之前，趁他还对他自己的情况有一定的知觉，我要带他再次走进这个世界，看看他会发生什么，以及他如何处理自己的事情。
They got a camera and went on a three-week trip, driving from Ft. Lauderdale back to New York City. Joel Meyerowitz's son Sasha did most of the filming. You hear his voice only a few times in the footage I'm about to play you. When they set out on the trip, Sasha was 27, Joel was 57, Hy was 87.
他们拿了一台摄像机，踏上了为期三周的旅程，从劳德代尔堡开车回纽约市。乔尔·迈耶罗维茨的儿子萨沙负责大部分拍摄。在接下来我要播放的片段中，你只能听到他的声音几次。当他们出发时，萨沙27岁，乔尔57岁，海伊87岁。
Do you know what ocean this is?
你知道这是什么海洋吗？
Well, I'll be honest with you, Joel. I don't remember. Not the Catskills Ocean--
说实话，乔尔。我不记得了。不是卡茨基尔海洋——
The Catskills are mountains. This is an ocean. Which one?
卡茨基尔是山脉。这是海洋。是哪一个？
Well, I don't know.
嗯，我不知道。
Is it the Pacific or the Atlantic?
是太平洋还是大西洋？
I will take that as Pacific.
我就当它是太平洋吧。
Really?
真的吗？
Wrong.
错了。
Wrong?
错了？
Yeah, wrong.
是的，错了。
So which one is it then?
那到底是哪一个？
It's the permiss- permission of--
是允许——允许的——
The Permishic. Right.
“允许洋”。对吧。
The Permishic!
“允许洋”！
The Farshimmelt. The Farshimmelt Ocean.
法希梅尔特洋。法希梅尔特海洋。
I am a bissel farshimmelt! What are you asking me so early in the morning a question like that?
我有点糊涂了！你一大早问我这种问题干什么？
Where were you born?
你在哪里出生的？
1-0-9-2-- 1-0-9-2-0-7-- no. 1-5-9-0-5-9 East--
1-0-9-2——1-0-9-2-0-7——不对。东1-5-9-0-5-9——
Well, it was East 100th Street, right?
嗯，是东100街，对吧？
Yeah. Yeah.
对。对。
He taught me all the street-smart things. He set up a punching bag for me. And he taught me how to fight, how to take my stance, how to throw a punch, how to put your body behind it. He had me work out on a light bag too, like this. He always felt that if you got into a scrape in the neighborhood that you shouldn't run away. His motto was, "Step in and deliver the first blow." And he said, "Take the biggest guy down."
他教我所有街头智慧的东西。他为我架设了一个沙袋。他教我如何打架，如何站位，如何出拳，如何用身体力量配合。他还让我练轻型沙袋，像这样。他总是觉得如果你在街区遇到麻烦，你不应该逃跑。他的座右铭是：“走上前去，先发制人。”他说：“把那个最大的家伙打倒。”
And that was his attitude. He wouldn't stop and run away from anything. On Morrison Avenue, the block we lived on, he was considered the mayor of the block. Anytime there was a dispute that had to be settled, they would actually come and ask him, "What do you think, Hy?" Or if there were strangers coming through the neighborhood and they needed to be told to get out of there, they'd get him. And the scenes I remember of it, people would gather in front of our window, and they'd yell, "Hymie? Hey, Hymie?" And he'd come to the window and he would adjudicate from the window. He would say, "No, no. You shouldn't do that. And he should do this. And you get that. Let him alone." And it was like The Judge.
这就是他的态度。他不会停下来，也不会从任何事情中逃跑。在莫里森大道，我们住的街区，他被认为是那个街区的“市长”。每当有纠纷需要解决，人们真的会来问他：“海伊，你怎么看？”或者如果有陌生人来到街区，需要被告知离开那里，他们就会叫他。我记得那些场景，人们会聚集在我们的窗前，喊着：“海米？嘿，海米？”他会走到窗边，从窗户进行裁决。他会说：“不，不。你不应该那样做。他应该做这个。你去拿那个。让他一个人待着。”这就像法官一样。
Here we come, baby. And I want you to know-- hey you!
我们来了，宝贝。我想让你知道——嘿，你！
[BIRD CHIRPING]
[鸟叫声]
Hello! Hello! Hello! Hello!
你好！你好！你好！你好！
Hey, Pop?
嘿，老爸？
What?
什么？
You know what this reminds me of?
你知道这让我想起了什么吗？
No.
不。
Does that remind you of Melvin?
这让你想起梅尔文了吗？
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
That's what I was thinking.
我刚才就在想这个。
I didn't think of the name at that time.
我那时没想起来名字。
Do you remember Melvin?
你还记得梅尔文吗？
Yeah. Sure I remember him.
记得。我当然记得他。
What was Melvin?
梅尔文是什么？
He was a little Chinese little bird.
他是一只中国小鸟。
A parakeet.
一只长尾小鹦鹉。
A parakeet. Right. I didn't think--
长尾小鹦鹉。对。我没想——
Do you remember the things that Melvin said?
你还记得梅尔文说的那些话吗？
He called us, he spoke to us, and he also called his name out a lot.
他呼唤我们，他跟我们说话，他也经常喊他自己的名字。
Yeah, but how did he say it? Do you remember?
是啊，但他怎么说的？你还记得吗？
"I'm Mel-- I'm Melvin!" Isn't it, isn't it, "Hi, Belvin?"
“我是梅——我是梅尔文！”不是吗，不是“嗨，贝尔文吗？”
No, he said, "I'm Melvin--" what?
不，他说，“我是梅尔文——”什么？
Melvin Belvin?
梅尔文·贝尔文？
"I'm Melvin Meyerowitz."
“我是梅尔文·迈耶罗维茨。”
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Can you tell me the story of the time he got lost--
你能告诉我他走丢的那次故事吗——
I can't tell you about-- look at this. I can't tell you about any-- look at this. Another one comes. Hiya, boys! Hello! Hello! We know you! We know your grandfather!
我不能告诉你关于——看这个。我不能告诉你任何关于——看这个。又来了一只。嘿，伙计们！你好！你好！我们认识你们！我们认识你们的爷爷！
Pop, remember how he used to say "My name is Melvin Meyerowitz. I'm a Jewish bird."
老爸，还记得他以前怎么说“我的名字是梅尔文·迈耶罗维茨。我是一只犹太鸟”吗？
Yeah. Yes.
是啊。是的。
That comes back to you?
你记起来了？
I know it. It didn't but that--
我知道。虽然刚才没想起来，但那个——
"Good morning, Dr. Goldberg."
“早上好，戈德堡医生。”
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
Whenever Dr. Goldberg came to visit Mom when she was sick?
每当戈德堡医生来看望生病的妈妈时？
Yeah.
是啊。
And do you remember the time the bird flew away across the Bronx? He went out the door on Mom's shoulder and he flew away. And we were all so heartbroken that the bird was gone. And then some woman called up. Do you remember? She called mom, and she said, "Do you have a bird named Melvin?" My mother said, "Yeah, we have a bird. It was a green and yellow parakeet." And the woman said, "Well, the bird landed on my window and said, 'My name is Melvin Meyerowitz. I'm a Jewish bird.' And I looked you up in the phone book, and I called the Meyerowitz's, and they said, 'No, no. That's my brother Hy's bird.'" We went and we got the bird back. Do you remember that?
你还记得那次鸟飞过布朗克斯区吗？他从妈妈肩膀上飞出门外跑掉了。我们都因为鸟丢了而心碎。然后有个女人打来电话。你记得吗？她给妈妈打电话，说：“你们有一只叫梅尔文的鸟吗？”我妈妈说：“是的，我们有一只鸟。是一只绿黄色的长尾小鹦鹉。”那个女人说：“好吧，鸟落在了我的窗台上，说‘我的名字是梅尔文·迈耶罗维茨。我是一只犹太鸟。’我就在电话簿里查了你们，打了给迈耶罗维茨家，他们说‘不，不。那是我弟弟海伊的鸟。’”我们去把鸟接了回来。你记得吗？
No.
不。
I'm surprised.
我很惊讶。
Come on! You don't want to go? Don't fall! Take it easy, take it easy. Do you want to go?
来吧！你不想走吗？别摔倒！放轻松，放轻松。你想走吗？
With the onset of memory loss, it's not only his memories that are fading away, but it's the memories that I shared with him that are fading away. So I could no longer say to him, "Hey Pop, remember we did this?" And have him say, "Yes, that was fantastic. Remember it?" So I found myself progressively left alone with my memories. And then you look at your own memories and you realize, I got this handful of really insignificant things, and I've made them my world, my world of memory.
随着记忆丧失的开始，不仅是他的记忆在消失，我和他共同的记忆也在消失。所以我再也不能对他说：“嘿，老爸，还记得我们做过这个吗？”然后让他说：“是的，那太棒了。记得吗？”所以我发现自己逐渐被留在了我自己的记忆中。当你审视自己的记忆时，你意识到，我手里只有这些微不足道的事情，我把它们当作了我的世界，我的记忆世界。
And it's astonishing how the few things that I recall to share with him are minor notes. The bird or the handful of things that I ask him. So that was really-- that was a lesson for me about what it is that rises up out of our experience that we hold onto.
令人惊讶的是，我能回想起来与他分享的那些事情竟然是一些小插曲。那只鸟，或者我问他的那几件事。所以，这对我来说确实是一个教训，关于我们从经验中汲取了什么并紧紧抓住不放。
Pop.
老爸。
Yes?
什么？
I want to ask you a few questions about the family.
我想问你几个关于家庭的问题。
About our family?
关于我们的家庭？
About our family.
关于我们的家庭。
Yes.
是的。
You've got three sons.
你有三个儿子。
Yes.
是的。
What are their names?
他们叫什么名字？
Joel, Ricky--
乔尔、瑞奇——
And who's your youngest son?
谁是你最小的儿子？
The youngest one is-- I think it was David. I don't remember the name anymore.
最小的是——我想是戴维。我记不得名字了。
Joel, Rick, and--?
乔尔、瑞奇，还有——？
Joel, Ricky, and-- yeah.
乔尔、瑞奇，还有——是啊。
Stevie.
史蒂夫。
Stevie. Oh, yeah.
史蒂夫。哦，是的。
OK. Do you know what Rick does to make a living? what his career is?
好的。你知道瑞奇是做什么职业的吗？
Well, he tries to do a lot of stuff for you. If he were following me, he would be doing  it on the crook. But--
嗯，他为你做了很多事。如果他跟着我，他会用那种不正当手段做。但是——
What's he famous for?
他以什么出名？
Ricky? Well, in the first place, he's my kid. You are also. And because that alone gives you enough fame.
瑞奇？首先，他是我的孩子。你也是。仅仅这一点就给了你足够的声望。
So you don't remember what Rick does?
所以你不记得瑞奇做什么？
Ricky? Rick is a half-time, or part-time book-- I don't know the trade names.
瑞奇？瑞奇是半职，或者兼职的——我不知道这些行业术语。
You're getting closer, Pop. Just try. Try to think about what Rick does.
你快想到了，老爸。试一试。试着想想瑞奇做什么。
Rick? Rick is an artist.
瑞奇？瑞奇是个艺术家。
Right! You got it.
对了！你答对了。
Not what?
不是什么？
You got it right. And I'm Joel. What do I do?
你答对了。我是乔尔。我做什么？
You're a doll. You're my best number one!
你是个可人儿。你是我的头号宝贝！
I know. Come on. Get serious, Pop. Do you remember what it is I do? What do I do?
我知道。来吧。认真点，老爸。你记得我是做什么的吗？我做什么？
You make money. I'll tell you what, I'll give it to you straight off the street.
你赚钱。我告诉你，我直接从街上跟你说。
What's my profession?
我的职业是什么？
What's what?
是什么？
What's my profession?
我的职业是什么？
What's your most attachment?
你最依恋的是什么？
What's my profession?
我的职业是什么？
Your profession. Now I've got to figure out-- I don't know. Crook or thief or whatever. You're known as an artist. Serious artist in the art field.
你的职业。现在我得弄清楚——我不知道。骗子还是小偷什么的。你是作为艺术家而出名的。艺术领域里严肃的艺术家。
OK, what about Stevie? What's Stevie's business?
好的，那史蒂夫呢？史蒂夫是干什么的？
Judy?
朱迪？
Stevie.
史蒂夫。
Stevie? I don't know.
史蒂夫？我不知道。
Does it bother you that you can't remember your kids' names sometimes and you can't remember what they do?
你有时记不住孩子的名字，也记不住他们做什么，这会困扰你吗？
Well, I'll tell you, yeah. I see them-- "Hello, goodbye." And that's it. I'm not complaining.
嗯，我告诉你，是的。我见到他们——“你好，再见。”就是这样。我没什么好抱怨的。
Is it hard to see him like this? Does it feel painful?
看到他这样很难受吗？感觉痛苦吗？
Honestly, it's sad. I have a feeling of sadness, but I also have a feeling of acceptance. We've been apart for 20 years in the mutual prime of our lives when I was raising my children and he was a grandparent. We weren't together.
老实说，很悲伤。我有一种悲伤的感觉，但我也有一种接受的感觉。在我们人生最巅峰的20年里，我们分开了，那时我正在抚养孩子，他当了祖父。我们没有在一起。
And so I guess I'm just accepting of where he is. If we had been together for 20 years and I had seen the decline and I had been relating to him emotionally and lovingly all that time, I might feel a deeper sadness. But even though he's my father, the distance that we've been apart all these years has put some kind of a buffer in there. So this is the guy that I know now.
所以我猜我只是接受了他现在的处境。如果我们一起生活了20年，我见证了他的衰退，并且在这段时间里一直与他进行情感和爱的交流，我可能会感到更深层的悲伤。但即使他是我的父亲，这些年来我们分开的距离在中间设下了一种缓冲。所以这就是我现在认识的这个人。
We have a much closer relationship, the way we see each other and talk to each other and have continuity.
我们现在的关系要亲密得多，我们见面、交谈并保持连续性的方式。
I just know at one point, you said to him he was your hero, which I thought was so sweet and I thought it must be hard to see--
我知道有一次，你对他说他是你的英雄，我觉得很甜蜜，我想看到——一定很难受。
A hero fall.
英雄陨落。
Right.
对。
Well, he was my hero. My childhood hero. But that's so far away, I can't relate to the sadness of that. I love him in that unequivocal way that a child loves a parent. And I feel when I care for him a kind of renewal or a rebirth of feeling in this period.
嗯，他曾是我的英雄。我童年的英雄。但这太遥远了，我无法体会那种悲伤。我以孩子爱父母的那种毫不含糊的方式爱他。当我照顾他时，我感到这段时期有一种更新或情感的重生。
I know when I take him after a shower and I rub him down, I actually feel his head in my hands and I feel his flesh in my hands. It's been many years since I had that kind of contact with my father. And it was a little strange at first. I thought, "What's it like to rub this other person's body? Touch this other person's body?" It's like deference. And then I realize it's my Pop. And he's in need. He can't take care of himself this way.
我知道当我带他洗完澡并为他擦干身体时，我真的感受到了他的头在我的手中，我感受到了他的血肉在我的手中。我已经有很多年没有和我父亲有过那种接触了。起初有点奇怪。我想，“抚摸这个人的身体是什么感觉？触摸这个人的身体？”这就像是一种尊重。然后我意识到这是我的老爸。他需要我。他无法这样照顾自己。
Mom? OK, here's Papa, Mom. Hold on. OK, here comes Dad.
妈妈？好的，这是爸爸，妈妈。等等。好的，爸爸来了。
Joel? Is it my Joel? Don't you know who I am? Who? What do you mean, "How come I'm on the phone?" Don't get mad at me. Don't get mad at me. It's very important because I've been traveling. I didn't--
乔尔？是我的乔尔吗？你不知道我是谁吗？谁？你是什么意思，“我怎么会在电话里？”别对我生气。别对我生气。这很重要，因为我一直在旅行。我没——
I think my father had a classic marriage of his generation. He loved my mother. She was beautiful and hot tempered, an exciting person to be with. But he wanted something from her that either he didn't know how to get or she couldn't give. And that was a kind of mother-love that he himself hadn't experienced.
我想我父亲那一代人的婚姻很典型。他爱我的母亲。她美丽、脾气火爆，是一个在一起时很令人兴奋的人。但他从她那里想要得到一些要么他不知道如何获得，要么她给不了的东西。那是一种他自己从未经历过的母爱。
Yes, I'm OK. No, I'm not having a good time. Are you having a good time? You are, really? OK. I want you to be healthy and strong and smile, Sally.
是的，我很好。不，我过得不开心。你过得开心吗？你是吗，真的？好的。我希望你健康强壮，微笑，萨莉。
His mother had been bed-ridden after his birth. And then she died soon after. So he never really knew her. That's the deepest groove in his memory, which is, I think, unrequited love.
他的母亲在他出生后就卧床不起了。随后不久就去世了。所以他从未真正了解她。那是他记忆中最深的印记，我认为是未获回报的爱。
Don't go down the judge's because right now I'm beginning the first one of Joel's tests. And I will be back at home maybe-- who knows? A couple of months from now. I don't know, Sally. Would you go with me the next trip? Would you go with me the next trip? OK. All right, May. Take care, sweetheart. Be careful, will you? Be careful. Bye bye.
别去法官那里，因为现在我正在开始乔尔测试中的第一个。我会回家，也许——谁知道呢？几个月后。我不知道，萨莉。你会和我一起去下次旅行吗？你会和我一起去下次旅行吗？好的。好吧，梅。保重，亲爱的。小心点，好吗？小心点。再见。
And I think from my point of view now that if he had really just loved my mother without demanding something from her, or needing something from her, which was that childhood need, that she probably would have just loved him back for the kind, warm, funny man that he was. But because there was something that he was demanding, she couldn't give it to him. A kind of perverse logic of relationship occurred.
我觉得从我现在的观点来看，如果他当初真的只是爱我的母亲，而不向她要求什么，或者不需要从她那里得到什么——那种童年的需求——那么她可能会仅仅因为他是一个善良、温暖、有趣的男人而爱他。但因为他有所要求，她无法满足他。一段关系的变态逻辑就此产生了。
She's mad. She's mad about something. Mad about me. I didn't do nothing.
她生气了。她对某事生气。对我生气。我什么都没做。
Why is she mad?
为什么她生气？
She's mad, that's all. She sounded very, very mad. She sounded like she didn't care.
她生气，就是这样。她听起来非常非常生气。她听起来好像不在乎。
Well, she probably was caring a lot--
嗯，她可能在乎得很多——
Oh, sure.
哦，当然。
--which is why she was mad. That we didn't call.
——这就是她为什么生气的原因。因为我们没打电话。
I waver also when I think of her being by herself. And I would rather be there than be here.
当我想到她独自一人时，我也很动摇。我宁愿在那里也不愿在这里。
But you're having such a good time here.
但你在这里玩得这么开心。
Yeah, to my limit, I'm having what I like and I would love to do, love to be involved with. But the idea is that I always have to include Mama.
是啊，我尽情享受我喜欢和愿意参与的事情。但关键是我总是得带上妈妈。
Throughout the trip, he asked for Sally every single day-- "Where's Sally? Where's Mom?"-- thinking that she should have been in the car next to him.
在整个旅程中，他每天都问起萨莉——“萨莉在哪里？妈妈在哪里？”——认为她本该坐在他旁边的车里。
Sally? Did you leave Sally upstairs there?
萨莉？你把萨莉留在楼上了吗？
Yeah, Pop. We said goodbye to Mom.
是啊，老爸。我们跟妈妈告别了。
No kidding. Right. Because I noticed right here that this is no Sally. I thought this was Sally all bundled up and I see it's that bundled up.
别开玩笑了。对。因为我注意到这里根本没有萨莉。我以为这是被包裹起来的萨莉，我发现它被包成了那样。
It's your pillow. That pillow's going to have to be your Sally--
那是你的枕头。那个枕头得当你的萨莉——
Yeah, yeah. The pillow.
是啊，是啊。枕头。
--for at least two weeks now.
——至少还得维持两个星期。
Oh, you guys are starting to pull tricks on me now. I know, I know, I know. Well, is she here?
哦，你们现在开始跟我开玩笑了。我知道，我知道，我知道。好吧，她在这里吗？
Nope. That's your pillow, Pop.
没有。那是你的枕头，老爸。
Jesus Christ almighty. I know she's not in the trunk. You wouldn't do that to her. I'm not able to come to this, Joel. I'm not the smartest and the cutest and the swiftest. I--
天哪。我知道她不在后备箱里。你不会那样对她的。我做不到这一点，乔尔。我不是最聪明、最可爱、最敏捷的。我——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
If my Mommy--
如果我的妈咪——
The swiftest!
最敏捷的！
If my Mommy don't come up and then don't come down in five minutes, I want to know where she is. This is my wife.
如果我的妈咪五分钟内不走上来也不走下来，我想知道她在哪。这是我的妻子。
So we better check the trunk.
所以我们最好检查一下后备箱。
Oh, the bed is in the trunk?
哦，床在后备箱里？
No.
不。
I wouldn't be surprised.
我一点也不会感到惊讶。
There was a time when we were driving with her in Florida, before we made the film. And she was sitting right next to him. And he leaned over to me and he said, "Where's Mom?" And I said, "Well, who's sitting next to you?" And he looked over at this person sitting next to him. He said, "Where's Sally? That's not Sally."
有一次我们在佛罗里达和她开车，拍电影之前。她就坐在他旁边。他俯身对我说：“妈妈在哪里？”我说：“嗯，谁坐在你旁边？”他看了看坐在旁边的那个人。他说：“萨莉在哪里？那不是萨莉。”
You can see better with this.
用这个你能看得更清楚。
Good morning.
早上好。
Good morning to you!
早上好！
Good morning, Pop.
早上好，老爸。
Hiya, Sonny.
嘿，儿子。
How are you doing?
你好吗？
I don't really know.
我真不知道。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
His real intelligence is to live in the moment. He knew where he was and he was just enjoying the experience. But he couldn't really look back at what he had done even an hour before and remember it. And I tested him all the time, because I wanted to see if stimulation could actually enliven his mentality and bring him back at all. But that was sort of a hopeless hope. But it didn't stop me from having it anyway.
他真正的智慧是活在当下。他知道自己在哪里，并且只是在享受这次经历。但他无法回顾甚至是一小时前所做的事情并记住它。我一直在测试他，因为我想看看刺激是否能真正活跃他的心智并让他恢复一点。但这只是一种绝望的希望。但这并不能阻止我怀有这个希望。
I just want to review a few things with you. I have a few questions for you.
我只是想和你回顾几件事。我有几个问题要问你。
Uh, I'm not-- I don't have to call my attorney?
呃，我不需要——我不必给我的律师打电话吧？
No.
不。
No. OK.
不。好的。
Do you remember any of the things on the trip so far?
你还记得旅途中的任何事情吗？
But will you-- I'm just going to say. Don't ask me about anything I did.
但你——我只是要说。别问我关于我做过什么的问题。
Why?
为什么？
Why? Because that's gone, man.
为什么？因为那都过去了，伙计。
It's gone.
都过去了。
Not that-- it wasn't so many things going on. But I just don't remember. It's jumbled. I've been to a car. I went to the automobile. I've been to the train. I was going in every direction. And I was losing sight. I was losing sight for no reason whatsoever. Everybody was going around us. Turmoil. Turmoiled.
并不是——没什么事发生。但我就是不记得了。乱糟糟的。我去了车上。我去了汽车。我去了火车。我往四面八方走。我失去了视野。我莫名其妙地失去了视野。每个人都在我们周围穿梭。动荡。动荡不安。
To moil?
去劳苦？
To moil is not to moil, but to moil is to have and to kiss and to love, to moil!
去劳苦不是去劳苦，但劳苦就是去拥有、去亲吻、去爱，去劳苦！
"Respect the old man who--" wait, wait. I can wear glasses.
“尊重那个老人，他——”等等，等等。我可以戴眼镜。
No, you can do this without glasses.
不，你可以不戴眼镜做到这一点。
Yes? OK. "Respect the old man who has forgotten what he learned from a broken table-- from a broken table tablet. Have a place in the urk--"
是吗？好的。“尊重那个老人，他忘记了他从破旧的桌子——从破旧的桌子平板上学到的东西。在方舟里占有一席之地——”
"Ark."
“方舟。”
"Ark. Ark. Besides the tablets of the law."
“方舟。方舟。除了律法石板之外。”
OK, now read it again. And for the first sentence, "respect the old man who has forgotten." Just read it that way.
好的，现在再读一遍。对于第一句，“尊重那个被遗忘的老人”。就那样读。
"Repsect the old man who has forgotten what he has learned. For broken tablets have a place in the mind-- in the ark, excuse me-- the ark besides the tablets of the law." Didn't I have my glasses here?
“尊重那个忘记了他所学知识的老人。因为破碎的石板在心中有一席之地——在方舟里，抱歉——除了律法石板之外的方舟。”我没把眼镜带这儿吗？
OK, now read it-- do you want my glasses?
好的，现在读——你想要我的眼镜吗？
I wanted to try it.
我想试一试。
Read it one more time. At the end say, "the Talmud." Because it says--
再读一遍。最后说，“塔木德”。因为它说——
The Talmud?
塔木德？
It says it comes from the Talmud. "Respect the old man who has forgotten what he has learned." Come to a rest. OK? Ready? Read.
它说它来自塔木德。“尊重那个忘记了他所学知识的老人。”休息一下。好的吗？准备好了？读。
With my glasses.
戴上我的眼镜。
We don't have your glasses here, Dad.
我们没带你的眼镜，爸。
Take--huh?
拿——啊？
You don't need your glasses. You read it perfectly without your glasses.
你不需要眼镜。你不戴眼镜读得太完美了。
All right. Because I thought maybe--
好吧。因为我以为也许——
Just do it one more time.
再试最后一次。
All right. "Respect the old man who has forgotten what he learned." [CLEARS THROAT] "For broken tablets have a place in the ark besides the tablets of the law." The Talmud. It was a little skimpy.
好吧。“尊重那个忘记了他所学知识的老人。”[清嗓子]“因为破碎的石板除了律法石板外，在方舟里也有一席之地。”塔木德。有点粗糙。
It was?
是吗？
It was a little skimpy, a little jumpy.
有点粗糙，有点跳跃。
Yeah. Put these glasses on and just see if they help you to read it.
是啊。戴上这些眼镜，看看它们能不能帮你读。
Maybe so.
也许吧。
Maybe so. One last time. This is it. This is your chance.
也许吧。最后一次。就是现在。这是你的机会。
All right.
好吧。
Otherwise you don't get the job.
不然你就得不到这份工作。
I don't have a-- I don't have--
我没有——我没有——
This is a casting session.
这是一个试镜环节。
Yeah, but maybe he's cock-eyed--
是的，但也许他是斜眼——
You've got enough light there, Pop. All you've got to do is try to read it.
那里有足够的光，老爸。你所要做的就是试着读它。
(SUBJECT) HY MEYEROWITZ: Yeah. I know I-- where is my-- didn't I bring my glasses up?
（被采访者）海伊·迈耶罗维茨：是的。我知道我——我的眼镜在哪——我没把眼镜带上来吗？
I don't know. They're away somewhere in a bag.
我不知道。它们不知道被放在哪个袋子里了。
OK.
好的。
Ready? Here goes. This is your screen test.
准备好了吗？开始。这是你的试镜。
Yes. "Respect the old man who has forgotten-- been-- who has forgotten what he learned. For broken ta--" only one thing. It was still shaking, my eye. That's why I was loose.
是的。“尊重那个老人，他忘记了——”只有一件事。它还在晃动，我的眼睛。这就是为什么我当时很松懈。
Take 11 for Hy Meyerowitz reading from "The Forgotten."
第11条，海伊·迈耶罗维茨阅读《被遗忘者》。
No. Take 11.
不。第11条。
Dad, this is-- no, no. Read that. No, no. This is a joke, Pop. Read those few words there. And then with the words "the Talmud." Nice and slow, take this one.
爸，这是——不，不。读那个。不，不。这是一个玩笑，老爸。读那几个词。然后加上“塔木德”那几个字。好好的，慢慢地，用这一个。
"Repsect the old man who has been forgotten, what he learned. For the broken tablets have a way place in the ark besides the tablets of the law." The Tablund-- Talmud. Ah, twice I made a mistake.
“尊重那个被遗忘的老人，他所学的知识。因为破碎的石板在方舟里有一席之地，除了律法石板之外。”塔布隆德——塔木德。啊，我犯了两次错误。
OK.
好的。
Well, I-- now that I know what I was doing--
好吧，我——现在我知道我在做什么了——
I guess as a legitimate actor, you would have a hard time reading your lines. But as a comic actor, you can deliver your lines flawlessly--
我想作为一个合法的演员，你会很难读台词。但作为一个喜剧演员，你可以毫无瑕疵地表演你的台词——
Yeah, yeah. An economist, yeah.
是啊，是啊。经济学家，是啊。
--without even having to read anything.
——甚至不需要读任何东西。
Yeah. Well, this one, I imagine, would have to be. Because this is the Talmud.
是啊。好吧，这个，我想应该会。因为这是塔木德。
Your career as a Talmudian actor--
你作为塔木德演员的职业生涯——
It just ended.
刚刚结束了。
--is kaput! You're finished. Out! Next! Bring in the next old man.
——完蛋了！你完了。出去！下一个！带下一个老人进来。
When my father was young, he was a wonderful dancer and athlete and a natural comic. And I guess Charlie Chaplin was the rage, and just as there were Elvis imitators, there were Chaplin imitators. And my father, he became a Chaplin imitator. And he had that act that I guess he took on the road, or around the vaudeville circuit in New York.
我父亲年轻时，是一位出色的舞者、运动员和天生的喜剧演员。我猜当时查理·卓别林很红，就像有猫王模仿者一样，也有卓别林模仿者。我父亲，他成为了一个卓别林模仿者。他那套表演，我想他可能带到路上演，或者在纽约的杂耍巡回演出中表演过。
I was trying to fit in myself, through all the years with the joking. I was trying to be a Chaplin. I didn't know if I was doing that right or wrong, but I saw that poor little guy, that he bent down, picked something up, everybody'd give him a kick in the ass. That was what I used to see. That is what I didn't want to happen to me.
多年来，我一直试图通过讲笑话来融入自己。我试图成为一个卓别林。我不知道我做得是对是错，但我看到那个可怜的小家伙，他弯下腰，捡起什么东西，每个人都会给他屁股一脚。那就是我过去看到的。那是我不想发生在我身上的事。
What was it that you liked about Charlie Chaplin that made you want to do the Charlie Chaplin act?
你喜欢查理·卓别林的什么，让你想做查理·卓别林的表演？
He was a giant in the height of a little midget. He was a little guy, went righting all the wrongs, helping others as he passed by. We'd pat him on the top of the head. He was remembered out there, just for a minute. He'd have a little [UNINTELLIGIBLE] with a little person hat and no money or no nothing. And he would go inside and he'd come out here like this. Like, shake his shoulders, and then travel around.
他是一个矮个子里的巨人。他是一个小家伙，纠正所有的错误，在他经过时帮助他人。我们会拍拍他的头顶。他在外面被记住了，哪怕只有一分钟。他会戴着一个带着一点[语音不清]的小帽子，没有钱或什么都没有。然后他会走进去，像这样走出来。比如，抖动他的肩膀，然后四处奔波。
And that was what I loved, the goodness, the goodness. And not everybody understood him. But those that understood him, they would put their arm around him and he would do the same with them. It was a beautiful deed for the day.
这就是我所热爱的，善良，善良。并不是每个人都理解他。但那些理解他的人，他们会把手臂搭在他身上，他也会对他们做同样的事。那是当天美丽的举动。
Did you feel connected to him in that way?
你觉得你和他在那方面有联系吗？
Always. [CHOKING UP] Always. Always.
一直都有。[哽咽]一直都有。一直都有。
Aw--
噢——
With Alzheimer's disease, most memory finally dissolves. And even though he was a man who was easily lovable, I think he forgot that these were his qualities. And that he was, in fact, loved by people faded from his memory. And at the end of his life, he remembers a few of the more painful things-- that he's a motherless child, that he was not loved the way he wanted to be loved. And it's amazing that with the murkiness of Alzheimer's clouding everything, that something as primal as being an unloved child stayed with him.
随着阿尔茨海默病，大部分记忆最终会消融。尽管他是一个很容易被爱的人，但我认为他忘记了这些是他的品质。而他实际上是被人们所爱的事实从他的记忆中消失了。在他生命的最后，他记得一些比较痛苦的事情——他是一个没妈的孩子，他没有得到他想要的爱。令人惊讶的是，尽管阿尔茨海默病的混浊笼罩了一切，但像作为一个未被爱的孩子这样原始的东西却留了下来。
When anybody would show a little bit of something to me that I was accepted, and they would talk to me, and they'd pat me on the top of the head of put their hands around me, I'm home. I loved everybody. I loved everybody. But nobody saw me. Nobody remembered me. Nobody knew me. Nobody saw me. But I was there. To this very day, I have the same fear. I have poor Mommy, I have. And she doesn't see me. She doesn't see me.
当任何人向我表现出一点点接受，他们和我说话，拍拍我的头顶或把手放在我周围时，我就回家了。我爱每个人。我爱每个人。但没人看见我。没人记得我。没人了解我。没人看见我。但我一直在那儿。直到今天，我还有同样的恐惧。我有可怜的妈咪，我有。但她看不见我。她看不见我。
Oh, Papa. Well, your boys saw you. We all saw you. I loved when you were the strong man in the neighborhood. I loved when you were the Chaplin figure and the comic. I loved the way you drove the car. You were such a great driver.
哦，爸爸。好吧，你的儿子们看见了你。我们都看见了你。我喜欢你做街区强人时。我喜欢你作为卓别林人物和喜剧演员时。我喜欢你开车的方式。你是一位如此出色的司机。
I love the way you talk to people. You could talk to the big guys or the little guys, and you made them all the same, Pop. I used to think of you as the great equalizer. You could take a guy who was a doctor or a principal of the school or a business man, and you can take another guy who was just an ordinary worker, and you would treat them the same. And you would bring them all to the same level, and that would be the level of laughter.
我喜欢你和人交谈的方式。你能和那些大人物或小人物交谈，你让他们都一样，老爸。我过去常把你当作伟大的平衡者。你可以把一个医生、校长或商人和一个普通工人放在一起，你会平等对待他们。你会把他们都带到同一个水平，那就是欢笑的水平。
You saw me. You saw Papa.
你看见我了。你看见爸爸了。
That's right.
那是真的。
Joel Meyerowitz. His father Hy, his son Sasha. Their film has the working title The Mayor of the Block and is looking for a distributor. Coming up, people do what they shouldn't. In a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
乔尔·迈耶罗维茨。他的父亲海伊，他的儿子萨沙。他们的电影暂定名为《街区市长》，正在寻找发行商。接下来，人们做他们不该做的事。公共广播国际台节目一分钟后继续。
We have arrived at Act Two of our show, My World Record. This is from a book by Tom Andrews called The Hemophiliac's Motorcycle .
我们进入了节目的第二幕，《我的世界纪录》。这是来自汤姆·安德鲁斯的书《血友病患者的摩托车》。
On November 15, 1972, one week after Nixon was reelected, I clapped my hands for 14 hours and 31 minutes.
1972年11月15日，尼克松连任一周后，我拍手拍了14小时31分钟。
[CLAPPING]
[拍手声]
I was listed in The Guinness Book of World Records. I was 11 years old.
我被列入了《吉尼斯世界纪录大全》。那时我11岁。
[CLAPPING]
[拍手声]
My record was published on page 449 of the 1974 edition of The Guinness Book , landlocked between the listings for largest circus and club swinging in the chapter entitled "Human Achievements." The listing read, "Clapping. The duration record for continuous clapping is 14 hours, 31 minutes by Thomas C. Andrews at Charleston, West Virginia on November 15, 1972. He sustained an average of 120 claps per minute at an audibility range of at least 100 yards."
我的纪录发表在《吉尼斯世界纪录大全》1974年版的第449页，夹在题为“人类成就”一章中“最大的马戏团”和“俱乐部挥杆”列表之间。记录上写着：“拍手。持续拍手的纪录是14小时31分钟，由托马斯·C·安德鲁斯于1972年11月15日在西弗吉尼亚州查尔斯顿创造。他平均每分钟拍手120次，可听范围至少为100码。”
I'm writing this from my bed at the University of Michigan hospital. It is 3:00 AM. It is the half-dark of hospitals at night. I've had an accident. I have been in an accident.
我是在密歇根大学医院的病床上写这些的。现在是凌晨3点。这是医院夜晚半暗的时刻。我出事了。我发生了一起事故。
[CLAPPING]
[拍手声]
"That your scrapbook?" Ellen, the night nurse, asked. When I mutter that technically it's my mother's who brought it to the hospital to cheer me up, Ellen glances at the Inquirer headline and says, "You did that, clap your hands?" I nod. "Lord! Did you have a major bleed, or what?"
“那是你的剪贴簿吗？”夜班护士艾伦问。当我嘟囔着说严格来说这是我母亲带来的，她带来医院是为了让我高兴，艾伦瞥了一眼《问询报》的标题说：“你做过那个，拍手？”我点头。“天哪！你是大出血，还是怎么了？”
[CLAPPING]
[拍手声]
"Dear Tom, it was certainly nice to read that you had broken the world record in clapping. We used to enjoy seeing how your dad recorded you and John in your annual picture for Christmas. The last few years, we had lost contact. Congratulations again. Everyone is very proud of you. Sincerely, the Ripley-Fishers."
“亲爱的汤姆，读到你打破了世界拍手纪录真是太好了。我们过去很喜欢看你爸爸如何在你的年度圣诞照片中记录你和约翰。过去几年，我们失去了联系。再次祝贺你。每个人都为你感到骄傲。真诚的，里普利-费舍尔一家。”
[CLAPPING]
[拍手声]
"Dear Tom, try to come out if you can. But if you can't, that's OK. I can play until about 4:00 or 5:00. I hope you come out. Will you walk with me today? Circle yes or no. I think you are the nicest boy over in Rolling Hills. I'm going to try to get you something. Love, Diane. PS-- write back if you want to. Don't let anybody else see this except Nan. If you want to. Or Laura. I just showed Nan and Laura. Do you mind? Circle yes or no. Answer questions and give back please."
“亲爱的汤姆，如果可以的话试着出来。如果不行，那也没关系。我大约可以玩到4点或5点。我希望你出来。你今天会陪我走走吗？圈出是或否。我觉得你是滚石山庄最好的男孩。我打算给你弄点什么。爱你的，黛安。PS——想回信就回。除了南，别让任何人看到这个。如果你愿意的话。或者劳拉。我只给南和劳拉看了。你介意吗？圈出是或否。回答问题并还给我，拜托。”
[CLAPPING]
[拍手声]
I have had an accident on the sidewalk. I watched my feet come out from under me on the iced concrete with a kind of anecdotal perspective. The bleeding inside the joints, the infusions of factor VIII, the weeks of immobility, the waiting for codeine, the inventions with which my mind would veer in the direction of solid ground. As my weight drilled into the twisting leg, I saw the whole pantomime emerge with the clarity of blown glass.
我在人行道上出过事故。我以一种轶事般的视角看着我的脚在冰冷的混凝土上滑开。关节内出血，第VIII因子输液，数周的不能动弹，等待可待因，我的思维趋向于踏实地面的发明。当我的重量钻进扭曲的腿里时，我看到了整个哑剧以吹制玻璃的清晰度显现出来。
[CLAPPING STOPS]
[拍手声停止]
When I told my hematologist that as a teenager I had raced motocross, that in fact in one race in Gallipolis, Ohio, I had gotten the holeshot and was bumped in the first turn and run over by 20-some motorcycles, she said, "No. Not with your factor level. I'm sorry but you wouldn't withstand the head injuries. You just like the sound of yourself being dramatic."
当我告诉我的血液学家我十几岁时曾参加摩托车越野赛时，事实上在俄亥俄州加利波利斯的一次比赛中，我抢到了起跑位置，却在第一个弯道被撞倒，并被20多辆摩托车碾过，她说：“不。你的因子水平绝对不行。很抱歉，你无法承受头部受伤。你只是喜欢听到自己戏剧化的声音。”
[CLAPPING]
[拍手声]
"Does he have to do that?" the waitress at the Pizza Hut asked. She passed out glasses of ice water from a tray, then set the tray down on the table.
“他非要那样做吗？”必胜客的服务员问。她从托盘里分发冰水杯，然后把托盘放在桌子上。
"He's breaking a world record," John said flatly.
“他正在打破一项世界纪录，”约翰淡淡地说。
"Does it bother you?" my mother said. "I can't make him stop, but we can leave."
“这困扰你吗？”我母亲说。“我无法让他停止，但我们可以离开。”
The waitress looked up. "You're joking, right? Let me see." She gestured for me to pull up my hands out from under the table. I showed my hands.
服务员抬起头。“你在开玩笑，对吧？让我看看。”她示意我把手从桌子底下拿出来。我展示了我的双手。
"He has to sustain an audibility range of at least 100 yards," John said.
“他必须保持至少100码的可听范围，”约翰说。
"I'm getting the cook," she said. "He's got to see this."
“我去叫厨师，”她说。“他得看看这个。”
A minute later, a man with botched teeth wearing a blue, dough-smeared apron was glaring at me. "Well?" he said, impatiently. Again I showed my hands. I speeded up just a little the rate of clapping. "Right. Unbelievable," the cook said, shaking his head and disappearing.
一分钟后，一个满口烂牙、围着蓝色脏围裙的男人正瞪着我。“怎么样？”他不耐烦地说。我又展示了我的手。我稍微加快了拍手的频率。“对。不可思议，”厨师摇着头消失了。
I said, "Can we order?"
我说，“我们可以点餐吗？”
"What do you do if you have to go to the bathroom?" the waitress asked.
“如果你必须去洗手间怎么办？”服务员问。
"I'd like a root beer," I said. "Do you have root beer?"
“我想要杯根汁啤酒，”我说。“你们有根汁啤酒吗？”
"He's trying to go the whole day without going," my mother said.
“他正试图一整天都不去，”我母亲说。
"Good luck," the waitress said.
“祝好运，”服务员说。
I said, "Do you have root beer?"
我说，“你们有根汁啤酒吗？”
"Yeah, they have root beer," John said.
“是的，他们有根汁啤酒，”约翰说。
I said, "I was asking her, thank you very much."
我说，“我是在问她，非常感谢。”
"I don't think I could go the whole day," the waitress said. "I think I have a weak bladder." I leaned over to John and whispered, "Help."
“我不觉得我能一整天不去，”服务员说。“我觉得我的膀胱很弱。”我靠向约翰耳语道，“帮帮我。”
"Hey," said the waitress, "how are you going to eat pizza?"
“嘿，”服务员说，“你打算怎么吃披萨？”
"I'm not," I said. "I'm just sipping some root beer. If you have it."
“我不吃，”我说。“我只是喝点根汁啤酒。如果你们有的话。”
"They have it. They have it," John said. John buried his head in his hands.
“他们有。他们有，”约翰说。约翰把头埋在手里。
"I'm going to feed him," my mother said.
“我来喂他，”我母亲说。
"No way," I said. For a second I forgot to clap, then caught myself and reestablished my rhythm.
“不行，”我说。有一秒钟我忘了拍手，然后回过神来重新确立了节奏。
"We'll have a large mushroom and pepperoni," my mother said, "and I'd like a glass of iced tea. What do you want to drink?"
“我们要一个大蘑菇辣香肠披萨，”我母亲说，“我还要一杯冰茶。你想喝什么？”
"I want a Coke," John said.
“我要可乐，”约翰说。
"Root beer," I said.
“根汁啤酒，”我说。
[CLAPPING]
[拍手声]
There are times in the last minutes before I am allowed-- or allow myself-- more codeine when the pain inside the joint simplifies me utterly. I feel myself descending some kind of evolutionary ladder until I become as crude and guileless as an amoeba. The pain is not personal. I am incidental to it. It is like faith, the believer eclipsed by something immense.
在我被允许——或允许自己——服用更多可待因之前的最后几分钟，关节内部的疼痛完全简化了我。我感到自己正在沿着某种进化阶梯下降，直到变得像阿米巴原虫一样原始而天真。疼痛不是个人的。我是它附带的。这就像信仰，信徒被某种巨大的东西遮蔽了。
[CLAPPING]
[拍手声]
After the waitress left, my mother lectured me about not participating in events we scheduled on John's off days, days when he wasn't on the dialysis machine. "You've known for a week that we were coming here. You could have picked another day for this clapping business." She said this in front of John, who grimaced and began looking around the room.
服务员走后，我母亲教训我，说我不参与我们安排在约翰休息日——他不进行透析的那几天——的活动。“你明明知道我们一周前就要来这里了。你可以为这个拍手的事选另一天。”她在约翰面前这样说，约翰做了个鬼脸，开始环顾四周。
My argument was that just being there at Pizza Hut while I was in the crucial early hours of breaking a world record was sufficient participation, and that sipping a little root beer under the circumstances put me solidly in the off-day spirit of things. She didn't see it that way.
我的论点是，只要在我打破世界纪录的关键早期阶段留在必胜客，就是足够的参与，而且在这种情况下喝点根汁啤酒使我坚定地融入了这种休息日的氛围。她并不这么看。
[CLAPPING]
[拍手声]
What surprised me was how easy it was to keep a precise and consistent rhythm. Two hours into the record, I felt as if my hands, like the legs of runners who have broken through the wall, could hammer away at themselves effortlessly and indefinitely. At that point, I knew I would not start a bleed. I had no doubt. And yet my hands kept hammering at themselves, hammering.
让我惊讶的是，保持精确和一致的节奏是多么容易。记录两小时后，我感觉双手就像冲破终点线的跑步者的腿一样，可以毫不费力、无限期地自我敲击。在那一刻，我知道我不会出血。我毫不怀疑。然而我的双手一直在敲击，敲击。
[CLAPPING]
[拍手声]
"Nixon's problem is he's not eating right," my mother said. "It's as plain as day. Anyone can see it. Just look at the man." It was 5:30 PM and I was still at it, 120 claps per minute.
“尼克松的问题是他吃得不健康，”我母亲说。“这很明显。谁都能看出来。看看那个人就知道了。”那时是下午5点30分，我还在继续，每分钟120次。
"Care for a drink?" my father said to himself. "Don't mind if I do. Thank you for asking."
“想喝一杯吗？”我父亲自言自语道。“我不介意。谢谢你的询问。”
[CLAPPING]
[拍手声]
For a long time, I asked John to come and watch me race. Again and again, he refused. Finally, he agreed to come to a race at Hidden Hills Raceway in Gallipolis, Ohio-- to shut me up, I think, as much as to satisfy his curiosity about his hemophiliac brother racing a motorcycle across the gouged wilderness. I knew John would have to wear a plastic bag over his shunt arm to keep the dust out. We were lucky it rained. Dust usually billowed wildly after the start of a race, a huge rolling wave breaking over the hills and shrouding the spectators. Rain would keep the dirt moist and on the track.
很长一段时间里，我请求约翰来看我比赛。他一次又一次地拒绝。最后，他同意来到俄亥俄州加利波利斯的隐藏山赛道——我想是为了让我闭嘴，也是为了满足他对患血友病的弟弟骑着摩托车穿越被挖开的荒野的好奇心。我知道约翰必须在他的分流手臂上套一个塑料袋以防灰尘进入。我们很幸运下了雨。尘土通常在比赛开始后狂乱地翻滚，像巨大的海浪一样翻过山丘，笼罩着观众。雨水会保持泥土湿润，留在赛道上。
Midway through the practice sessions, however, the rain stopped. By the time of the first 125 moto, dust forced John into the cab of the pickup. That is the image that attacks me now-- John in the truck, windows rolled up, reading a book to pass the time while I kicked up the dust all around him.
然而在练习赛中途，雨停了。到第一场125摩托车赛时，灰尘迫使约翰进了皮卡车的驾驶室。那是我现在脑海中浮现的画面——约翰在卡车里，窗户摇上，读着书打发时间，而我在他周围扬起了尘土。
Random symmetries. Days when John's shunt clotted and he required I forget how many cc's of heparin to get his blood to stop coagulating. Meanwhile, I'd start a bleed and would need cryoprecipitate or factor VIII to get my blood to clot.
随机的对称。约翰的分流管堵塞，他需要我忘记多少毫升的肝素来阻止血液凝固的日子。与此同时，我会开始出血，需要冷沉淀物或第VIII因子来让血液凝固。
More x-rays. I've stopped bleeding into the spinal muscles. Soon enough, my hematologist says my body will loosen and break down and absorb the hardened blood surrounding the spine, as it had been doing in my leg. There has been no intraspinal bleeding, no bleeding into the kidney or liver. I look at Carrie. I look at my mother and father. We are inside a sudden, astonishing calm. I seem to levitate and hover over the white sheets.
更多的X光检查。脊柱肌肉已经停止出血。我的血液学家说，不久之后，我的身体就会松开、分解并吸收脊柱周围硬化的血液，就像在我的腿上发生的那样。没有脊髓内出血，没有肾脏或肝脏出血。我看着嘉莉。我看着我的父母。我们处于一种突然的、令人惊讶的平静中。我似乎漂浮在白床单上。
[CLAPPING]
[拍手声]
Once when John was dialyzing, I tripped into the machine and jerked a tube clean out of its socket. John's blood pumped and sprayed into the air, splattering across the carpet and splotching our skin and clothes. My mother worked frantically to reconnect the tube and to stabilize John's blood pressure. Later, I noticed that some of the blood had seeped inside a picture frame in the wall besides the dialysis chair. The frame held a photograph of John and me. We were wading in the Kanawha River, staring hard at the gray water.
有一次约翰正在进行透析时，我绊进了机器，硬生生把一根管子从插座里拔了出来。约翰的血液喷涌而出，洒向空气，溅落在地毯上，并沾染了我们的皮肤和衣服。我母亲疯狂地试图重新连接管子并稳定约翰的血压。后来，我注意到一些血迹渗入了透析椅旁墙上的相框内。相框里装着约翰和我的照片。我们正在卡纳瓦河中涉水，死死盯着灰色的河水。
[CLAPPING]
[拍手声]
Excerpts from Tom Andrews' prose poem "Codeine Diary." It's in his book The Hemophiliac's Motorcycle and was read by Frank Melcori.
摘自汤姆·安德鲁斯的散文诗《可待因日记》。它在书《血友病患者的摩托车》中，由弗兰克·梅尔科里朗读。
Act Three, Iron Man. All of our stories today have been at one level about yearning briefly fulfilled. And we thought this last story would be a perfect way to end this show. Mark O'Brien is a writer living in California, but because of a childhood case of polio, he lives most of each day in an iron lung, on his back. He's the subject of the documentary film Breathing Lessons by Jessica Yu. The film is remarkable because it's about a guy in an iron long, but it is completely unsentimental. There are even parts where it's funny.
第三幕，“钢铁侠”。我们今天所有的故事都在某种程度上关于短暂实现的渴望。我们认为这个最后的故事将是结束这个节目的完美方式。马克·奥布赖恩是一位住在加州的作家，但因为童年时期患过小儿麻痹症，他每天大部分时间都躺在铁肺里，仰卧着。他是杰西卡·余执导的纪录片《呼吸课程》的主题。这部电影非常了不起，因为它讲的是一个躺在铁肺里的人，但它完全没有感伤。甚至还有一些部分非常有趣。
This is a brief scene from the film. Because he's in the iron lung, Mark O'Brien has attendants. They cook and they help him out during the day. And during the film, he explains that nowadays he always has men do this job. Because back when he had women do the job, he kept falling in love with these women, and the love was never reciprocated. He wrote about one of these women, "Her pale, perfect skin, her strong, fleshy legs drove me to ecstasies of despair. See, she talked to me as a human instead of her savagely crippled employer."
这是电影中的一个简短场景。因为他在铁肺里，马克·奥布赖恩有护理人员。他们负责做饭，并在白天帮助他。在电影中，他解释说如今他总是雇佣男性做这项工作。因为当他雇佣女性时，他总是会爱上这些女性，而爱从未得到回报。他写道其中一个女性：“她苍白、完美的皮肤，她强壮、肉感的双腿让我陷入绝望的狂喜。你看，她把我当作一个人来谈话，而不是作为她严重残疾的雇主。”
A quick warning before I play this very brief scene. It contains mild sexual content that may not be suitable for every listener.
在播放这个非常简短的场景之前有一个简短的警告。它包含可能不适合所有听众的轻微性内容。
[IRON LUNG RESPIRATION]
[铁肺呼吸声]
I hired a sex-surrogate in-- '87 or '86. I forget when. I just-- felt very crazy. I was-- angry at all women for not falling in love-- with me, because I had fallen in love with several-- attendants. And they-- all said it was a business rela-- tionship.
我在87年或86年雇佣了一个性替代者。我忘了什么时候。我只是——感觉非常疯狂。我对所有女性没有爱上我感到愤怒，因为我曾爱上了几个护理人员。她们都说这是一种商业关系。
A sex surrogate's a person who has some of psychological training that-- works with their body, having sex with a client who's recruited by a therapist. The surrogate had this big mirror and she-- saw me naked and aroused. And-- at the time, I thought I was the ugliest man in the world. I looked just like something someone-- wouldn't want to have sex with.
性替代者是一个受过心理训练，与身体一起工作，与治疗师招募的客户进行性行为的人。那个替代者有一面大镜子，她看见我赤身裸体并处于兴奋状态。在当时，我觉得自己是世界上最丑的男人。我看起来就像一个人不想与之发生性关系的某种东西。
And Cheryl was very kind to me. She kissed me on the chest after-- we had intercourse. I felt my-- chest was very unattractive, but-- she kissed me right there. And-- the intercourse was so quick, it just-- I hate to say it, but it was wham, bam, thank you ma'am. And it-- wasn't as great as I thought it would be, but-- being naked in a bed with a woman who's being extremely friendly was the-- most fun I've ever had. I think I'd like to do it again.
谢丽尔对我非常好。在我们发生性关系后，她亲吻了我的胸部。我觉得我的胸部非常没吸引力，但她就在那里亲了我一下。而且性交太快了，就像是“快进快出，谢谢你，夫人”。这并不像我想象的那么好，但在床上与一个极其友好的女性赤身裸体是我有过的最有趣的体验。我想我愿意再做一次。
Usually Mark O'Brien can't be outside of his iron lung for more than 45 minutes. But when the sex surrogate was with him, he was outside his tube for longer than that, longer than he almost every goes out. And he didn't even use his portable respirator.
马克·奥布赖恩通常在铁肺外待的时间不能超过45分钟。但当性替代者和他在一起时，他在管子外的时间超过了这个限度，比他几乎去任何地方的时间都要长。他甚至没用他的便携式呼吸机。
I didn't need it for an hour. I went for-- an hour without it. It makes you think of sex as respiratory-- therapy. Maybe Medi-Cal would pay for it. About a year after I last saw her, I just felt terribly depressed. I expected somehow that seeing the surrogate would change my life. I had started wearing cologne. And I thought everyone would be able to tell if I was sexy and handsome.
我有一小时不需要它。我不戴它过了一个小时。这让你把性看作是一种呼吸疗法。也许Medi-Cal会为此买单。我最后一次见到她大约一年后，我感到非常沮丧。我原本期待看到那个替代者会改变我的生活。我开始擦古龙水。我以为每个人都能看出我是否性感帅气。
Nothing happened. They tell us to think of ourselves as-- sexual and beautiful, but it doesn't do any good-- unless someone else sees us as sexual and beautiful. You just can't demand love. You-- have to be lovable, and-- I'm still trying to figure out how to do that.
什么都没发生。他们告诉我们把自己看作是性感的和美丽的，但这没用——除非别人也把我们看作是性感的和美丽的。你不能强求爱。你必须是可爱的，而我还在试图找出如何做到这一点。
Mark O'Brien in Jessica Yu's film, Breathing Lessons. O'Brien has a new book of poems called The Man in the Iron Lung published by the Lemonade Factory in Berkeley.
马克·奥布赖恩在杰西卡·余的电影《呼吸课程》中。奥布赖恩有一本名为《铁肺里的人》的新诗集，由伯克利的柠檬工厂出版。
Well, our program was produced today by Alix Spiegel and myself, with Nancy Updike and Julie Snyder. Contributing editors Paul Tough, Sarah Vowell, Jack Hitt, and Margy Rochlin.
好的，我们的节目今天由阿利克斯·斯皮格尔和我本人制作，南希·厄普代克和朱莉·斯奈德协助。特约编辑：保罗·塔夫、莎拉·沃威尔、杰克·希特和玛吉·罗克林。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Music help, as always, from Sarah Vowell. To buy a tape of this program, call us at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380. Our email address, [email protected] . This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
音乐帮助一如既往来自莎拉·沃威尔。要购买此节目的磁带，请致电芝加哥的WBEZ，电话312-832-3380。我们的电子邮箱地址是[email protected]。此《美国生活》节目由公共广播国际台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who can be heard in his office every day, saying--
WBEZ的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他每天都能在办公室里听到他说——
Don't you know who I am? Who? What do you mean how come I'm on the phone?
你不知道我是谁吗？谁？你是什么意思，“我怎么会在电话里？”
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
Next! Bring in the next old man.
下一个！带下一个老人进来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际台。